Đây đấy, em đang làm nó đang hơi không kiểm soát được ạ
Thì đề tài của em là em sẽ cố gắng sử dụng GAN trong
Tên của anh
À vâng, em có, em viết tiếng Anh, quên chưa đổi lại
Thì em dùng GAN để tấn công SQL
bài toán thì hiện tại là dữ liệu thì sẽ hầu hết sẽ là các dữ liệu của người dùng rất bình thường
đôi lúc mới có dữ liệu tấn công thì tỷ lệ sẽ rơi khoảng từ 100 trên 1 thì tới 1.000 trên 1
thì theo phương pháp bình thường thì mình sẽ chỉ đơn giản là lọc dữ liệu rồi chuyển nó thành vector
có thể dùng MOT để kiểu định dạng lại thì lúc này mình sẽ dùng GAN bởi vì GAN nó có thể học
Còn cái thằng kia nó chỉ đơn giản nội sinh, nghĩa là mình đưa cho nó cái gì thì nó cũng chỉ thay đổi các string
Nó chỉ học nội sinh thôi nhưng nó không có khả năng sinh ra những cái dữ liệu mới để mình có thể học tiếp
Thế em mới đề xuất ra, thì đây là mô hình của em ạ
Thì đầu tiên là em sẽ lấy dữ liệu, lấy dữ liệu trên Kaggle và một số cái Datap
lấy thêm dữ liệu của các cái CVE, nghĩa là người ta ghi nhận những cái tấn công
dữ liệu thì em lấy, thì em cũng mới chỉ lấy khoảng 30.000
bởi vì là dữ liệu tấn công thực tế
thì khi mà em làm thì em thấy là hầu hết là nó chỉ là noise
nghĩa là nó chỉ có khả năng tấn công
lúc mà em gõ thật thì khả năng tấn công thực tế của nó là không có
nó khá là ít, này em mới nhận ra
còn tiếp theo là
trong mô hình nó sẽ có 2 thành phần
đầu tiên là thành phần Generate
và thành phần Qua lịa và thành phần Quy tích
thì em có thêm vào là
trong này sẽ có thêm
trong thành phần này em sẽ có thêm
cái Mutation
Criticization nghĩa là em sẽ cho nó biết định nghĩa cho cả hai thằng
Gây nhiễu của nó
Cái này là em cũng mới tìm hiểu
Thì em đang hiểu là em sẽ cho nó biết là
Bây giờ SQL injection thì nó sẽ phải có những điều kiện tối thiểu là gì
Em cho cả hai thằng nó học luôn
Còn nếu mà làm theo quyền bình thường thì nó đang hơi loạn
Sau khi mà Critic thành công xong
sau đó em sẽ có thêm một lớp để trách nữa thì nó sẽ gồm 3 cái đầu tiên là kiểm tra xem có phải là
SQL không ạ là cái L1 tiếp theo là sẽ kiểm tra xem là khả năng injection của nó nghĩa là xem là thực
tế nó có khả năng tấn công không ạ Hiện tại là em mới chỉ cho quét qua bộ thư viện OpenSource ở trên
mạng rồi ạ còn cái số 3 là em sẽ quét xem là độ đa dạng xem là nó có thật sự đa dạng nghe nó có thật
thật sự hơn được thay thế được em thay được thằng small không ạ thì trong tương lai thì em sẽ thay
thế cái thằng l2 bằng cách là em cho tấn công thực tế trên các tương lửa thông dụng ạ và cái cuối
cùng là các cái thước đo để xem là mô hình của em đạt những giá trị nào thì em cũng vận thì đây là
kết quả thì nếu như mà tỷ lệ mà rất rất cân bằng như kiểu 500 trên 1 ạ cái cổ ngoài cùng ạ thì là
là nó thì cái mô hình sẽ gan nó sẽ hơn được cái phương pháp cơ bản là 42 phần trăm nhưng mà càng
lên cao thì nếu mà tỷ lệ càng thấp thì thằng mốt nó sẽ thắng được thằng gan thì tỷ lệ đem chọn là
100 100 trên một là tỷ em cho rằng tỷ lệ mất cân bằng đủ để mình có thể dùng phương pháp ra thì
Ở hình bên phải, em cũng thử chia ra 4 trường hợp
Nghĩa là trong tấn công SQL sẽ có 4 trường hợp
2 trường hợp đầu tiên là Boolean và Error
Thì cái này dựa trên phản hồi của máy chủ
Nghĩa là nó không thực sự tấn công
Nó sẽ đợi xem phản hồi máy chủ là gì
Và từ đó họ sẽ mường tượng xem hệ thống của mô hình là như nào
Thì nên là 2 cái đầu là nó sẽ không có đặc biệt
Bởi vì nó chỉ đơn giản là tấn công những cái mà mình đã biết rồi ạ
Nhưng mà 2 cái cuối cùng là sẽ cố gắng tấn công vào cơ sở dữ liệu hoặc là máy chủ ạ
Thì khi này thì nó mới thật sự có khác biệt ạ
Thì ở đây là mô hình GAN mà khi tấn công Time Experience Action thì là hơn được 11%
Và nếu mà tấn công Union Bay thì sẽ là 7% ạ
Thì đây là lược đồ Training Curve của em ạ
Thì khi mà em Training khoảng 50 Epoch thì nó sẽ chững lại ạ
Thì ở đây thì là ở mô hình dưới cùng cái số 3 ạ
Thì là cái đầu tiên thì là khi mà đạt tới 50 Epoch
Thì là từ về sau em sẽ chỉ tạo ra S-Conjection chứ không còn tạo nhiều nữa ạ
Nhưng mà còn diversity thì là em đang không để kéo lên trên 0.6
Nghĩa là nó cũng không để sinh ra được cái dữ liệu SQL Action mà nó thật sự nằm ngoài
Nó thật sự nằm ngoài, nghĩa là nó có đem ra sự khác biệt
Khác hẳn so với cái baseline bình thường của em
Thì đây là cái vấn đề lớn nhất mà hiện tại em đã tạo lại
Nghĩa là dùng GAN nhưng mà không đáng kể
Nghĩa là nếu mà chỉ đơn giản là tạo ra khoảng 0.5 thì có thể vừa dùng SMODE được nó cũng không tạo ra khác biệt lớn
Đây là cái em đang thiếu định hướng nhất ạ
Thiếu định hướng cái gì?
Dạ
Nghĩa là về độ đa dạng ạ, em đang muốn sử dụng GAN để sinh ra cái dữ liệu tấn công nó đa dạng ạ
Còn nếu mà nó chỉ rơi vào khoảng
Quality của em nó chỉ 0.5
Thì chứng tỏ là dữ liệu em
Nó cũng không thật sự quá đa dạng
Nó cũng chỉ đơn giản là ghép đi ghép lại
Cái string nó không học được cái mới
Đây là vấn đề lớn nhất
Mà em đang khá lo lắng
Vẫn như em vẫn đang tìm hiểu
Còn lại là
Hai cái còn lại thì là đầu tiên là
Có phải là dữ liệu SQL không
Hoặc là có phải tấn công không
Thì nó trên 0.9
thì nó cũng có thể chấp nhận được
thế thôi thì?
còn một vấn đề nữa
đây ạ
thì là sau khi mà trend xong
thì là tất cả các M1 của em
đều ra là 0,99%
nghĩa là em đang sợ
là nó đang bị overfit và đang
không sinh ra sự khác biệt
nghĩa là kể cả em có dùng phương án cũ
hay là phương án gan
hay là gì nữa thì
hello, xin chào trưởng
Đây là các chỉ số Matrix thì là cả 4 cái kích bản thì nó không có sự khác biệt ạ và nó thường đạt trên chỉ 9% ạ.
Đây là một vấn đề mà em tìm phương án giải quyết.
Hiện tại là phương án giải quyết mà em đang tìm hiểu thì chỉ có là em sẽ sử dụng thay vì em sẽ sử dụng thêm cả cái top k neutral code để có thể tăng độ đa dạng
Thì em đang mong là nó có thể đem ra sự khác biệt
Thì đấy là toàn bộ phần báo cáo của em
Bây giờ như thế này nhé, em phải chuẩn bị lại cái slide này
Chuẩn bị lại cái slide này và làm rõ mình như thế này
Thứ nhất là cái bài toán, em giải quyết nó là gì, đúng
Bài toán em giải quyết là gì?
Bài toán của em là dùng GAN để phát hiện hay để sinh dữ liệu để hỗ trợ quá trình phát hiện SQL Injection
Đúng không?
Nếu mà mình xem ở đây thì mục tiêu của em đề ra là phân tích thực trạng của vấn đề của nó nhé
Hình cứu phân tích các kỹ thuật phát hiện vòng trống SQL Injection không cần nói nữa nhé
để xuất mô hình giải pháp tổng thể nâng cao hiệu quả phát hiện
Trong đó nhấn mạnh việc ứng dụng mô hình xin dữ liệu để bổ sung dữ liệu tấn công
Nhưng trọng tâm của em là vẫn phải có một mô hình phát hiện tấn công
Sau đó mình chỉ ra với dữ liệu nó như thế này
Đặc biệt là mức cân bằng thì người ta có thể dùng SMOTE đúng không?
Nhưng thay vì SMOTE thì tôi dùng GAN đúng không?
Đấy cái logic của mình nó chỗ đấy đúng không?
Như vậy là em chạy được GAN nên em rất phải so sánh với SMOTE đúng không?
Em xin em hỏi, nghĩa là bây giờ em có cần kiểu đưa ra tỷ lệ
ví dụ như là 100 trên 1 hoặc là 80 trên 1 thì mới nên dùng GAN hoặc mới nên dùng SMOTE không ạ?
Đấy là kết quả về sau thôi.
Nếu mà mình ra thì cũng bị cắn tốt, còn nếu không thì trước mắt là làm sao để mình ra thì chúng ta phải sinh ra dữ liệu
Dùng smart hoặc dùng gai
Như vậy là em phải có các bộ phát hiện thì bộ phát hiện của em nó là gì?
Bộ phát hiện của em thì sẽ có 3 cái, đầu tiên là có 3 cái thư viện
SQL 3 là để check xem có phải SQL không
Một cái SQL Injection Library là để kiểm tra xem phải tấn công không
và cái cuối cùng là sẽ xem là có đa dạng hay không
Cái này là cái tool mình đang áp dụng trên đây để kiểm tra môi phục máy
Môi phục máy thì em mới chỉ đưa ra kịch bản bình thường
Dùng cái gì thường lý? Môi phục máy thì để kiểm tra hiện
Sẽ có đúng không?
Vâng
À không em có dùng cái cơ bản là cái quyết định
Cái baseline của em là gì?
Baseline của em là dùng 2 cái cơ bản là cây quyết định với cả là
cái gì nhỉ, tuyến tính, quên tên rồi
Đấy em liệt kê cho thầy, trong slide em liệt kê cho thầy là các bộ
phát hiện thấy nó là những bộ gì, theo thầy nên ý tuyển bao
có thể là cây quyết định hay gì là ý tuyển bao
Rồi
Đấy
Và với 3 bộ đấy mình chạy trên các phương pháp sinh dữ liệu
Trong đó mình trọng tâm sẽ vào gan đúng không?
Nhưng để nắm được là gan có tốt hay không thì phải so sánh với các phương pháp khác như là SMOTE
Đấy cái logic của luật ban anh hiểu chưa em nhé?
Em hiểu
Đấy, đối với luật ban này sau khi em đã sửa tư đề thì nó cũng không nhất thiết là phải là thứ gì mới cả đúng không?
Đấy, nếu mà mình có mới thì mình sẽ đảm bảo, không thì mình sẽ làm nó bắt đúng chưa?
Đấy, thế còn là tiếp theo là bộ dữ liệu của em là gì?
Đấy, em muốn giảm rõ thầy, em bổ dữ liệu, em lấy ở đặc trưng nó là những cái gì, một cái bản ghi dữ liệu trong đấy, cấu trúc nó như thế nào, mình sẽ thực hành.
Giải thích cho thầy SMODE nó sẽ làm như thế nào, giải thích cho thầy GAN là gì, CT GAN là gì, CW GAN là gì?
Những cái đấy là mình giải thích kiểu bằng văn hay là phải có bài toán học được.
Khi giải thích VNM thì mình phải giải thích kiểu bằng văn nói hay là có văn toán nữa
Văn toán nhiều đâu, văn toán trong luật văn
Còn slide để dẫn dắt vấn đề
Thì GAN, CT GAN, CTW GAN
3 anh ấy có khác nhau cái gì
Thậm chí em có thể chạy cả 3 anh ấy
GAN truyền thống này, CT GAN này, CW GAN
Thì đưa thầy bảo tích tại sao mọi người tự lựa chọn CW GAN
Anh nghiên cứu nó phải thế không?
Vâng
Được chưa?
Như thầy hiện tại thì cái của em nó đang bị overfit
Thì em đang mong muốn là thầy cho em keyword hoặc là
Một cái keyword để em có thể tìm phương án giải quyết được không?
Overfit thì có thể có mấy lý do như thế này
Nhất là cái mô hình gan đấy có thể là nó lệch giữa Generator và Dissimilator
Critic là khả năng này yếu, đúng chưa?
Thứ hai là cái bộ dữ liệu, xem lại bộ dữ liệu
Nếu chẳng hạn nó lệch quá thì cũng có thể sinh gan cũng không dễ, đúng không?
Đấy, chiếc mắt đầu mình mình cũng chọn bộ dữ liệu nó lệch đủ vừa thôi
Đừng lệch quá mức, để xem nó xem như thế nào
Hiện tại em lấy hầu hết chỉ có lệch 1.1 hoặc 1.2 nên là em đang phải cố gắng cắt bớt xuống một tí ạ
Cắt xuống khoảng 1 trên 50 thì lúc đấy thì gan của em mới phát huy tác dụng nha là mới hợp được
Thế tiếp theo này, câu hỏi tiếp theo là đã có ai đã dùng gan này để sinh dữ liệu cho cái bài báo này thế chưa?
Có em có tham khảo cho nó ở đâu rồi đưa lên xin thông tin xem người ta làm cái gì đúng không?
Có 6 bài báo khoa học có làm giống em ạ
Nhưng mà họ không chia như em là kiểu họ không chia các dạng vật công mà họ chỉ bê nguyên H1N1 vào thôi ạ
Thì đấy là em đang coi như là điểm mới của em
Đầu tiên mình phải làm cái cơ bản này ạ
Đấy cơ bản nó chạy ổn thì bắt đầu đi ra cái mới được
Có lý lúc lộ tục theo cũng biết được một lần rồi
Được chưa?
Được
Đấy thế giới cũng thoải mái
Ngoài ra em cũng đang hơi lo. Kết quả nó không được nghĩ.
Nó phải rõ ràng như thế thôi. Thầy cho bàn nó biết được anh ạ.
Vâng ạ.
Cái diversity là em đổ đo một tí. Cách đo như thế nào?
Em đưa qua một cái thư viện. Em có một bài báo là ESBL.
Người ta có bảo người ta lấy thư viện.
Ba này thì cái ý tưởng với ba bộ quality filter là em lấy từ một bài báo.
Người ta có đăng thư viện cho em đưa về để em thử
Đấy, trong slide em mô tả thầy công thức kỹ tính
Vâng
Thì ta ghi bàn được
Rồi
Bây giờ người ta bảo muốn làm trời làm biển gì
Nhưng mà nếu mà có thích tóm lại dữ liệu anh định dạng làm gì mình trả lời thì xin
Đúng không
Em về trong slide mình nói rõ ràng
Đây thầy, em mô tả thầy xem là một bản ghi nó như thế này
Đúng không
Đấy, đúng chưa
Với sinh ra thì thường nó sẽ thay đổi cái gì nữa thế?
Hãy trình bày lại thầy nào
Chúng tôi mong muốn sớm ạ
Chiều thứ bảy ạ
Chiều
thứ bảy ạ
có kịp không?
hay là sang tuần sau?
chiều thứ bảy em chắc là không kịp
em mong là sang tuần sau
chắc là bằng lời tuần sau
thứ ba hoặc thứ năm được
ok, tuần tuần đi
anh cảm ơn ạ
đấy, tự mình cũng phải nắm vào thầy
thế thì nó ra cũng được
vâng
nhé
bây giờ bắt đầu vào giai đoạn làm rồi đấy
kinh nghiệm là
cũng làm dân làm được với đến tức cả
thì chắc là em cũng
thầy nói thế chắc em cũng phải cân nhắc
cũng phải đập đi một xíu cái
Bởi vì là em đang bị mong muốn thông số đẹp nên là có bà đâu cứ lên đọc vài báo nào thấy có su đu hướng có thể sửa em đập hết vào.
Tức là thầy cứ chạy ra rồi bắt đầu đi sang cái tivi.
Được chưa?
Vâng thầy ạ.
Ra đây nhé.
Ra đây thầy ạ.